in his book the mind of the market
Michael Shermer argues there's an
evolutionary basis for economic theory
the event from the Cato Institute in
Washington DC is an hour good afternoon
and welcome to the Cato Institute my
name is David Bose I'm the executive
vice president of the Institute and I'm
glad to welcome all of you here for what
I think will be a very interesting
discussion of a new book today there's
lots of debate about the best arguments
for freedom and capitalism Iran insisted
that you could only arrived at
libertarian conclusions on the basis of
her metaphysics epistemology and ethics
lock and Spencer helped to outline a
rigorous and consistent theory of
natural rights Hume actin and Hayek
instead would direct our attention to
the historical processes by which
Liberty was achieved in the west milton
friedman would offer a consequentialist
case people will enjoy more peace and
prosperity if markets are allowed to
work so it's interesting to see that our
speaker today Michael Shermer has titled
today's talk the case for capitalism
from an evolutionary perspective a new
way of arriving at perhaps a similar
conclusion and I think the more
different lines of argument point in the
same direction the more confident we can
be that that's the right conclusion dr.
Michael Shermer is the founding
publisher of skeptic magazine and the
executive director of the skeptics
society he's also a monthly columnist
for Scientific American he is the author
of many books on science and the science
of thinking I don't see how you can
publish a magazine and be executive
director of an organization and write
this many books and yet I've read some
of them and I know that he's not
skimping on the time he spends their his
last book which he also presented at the
Cato Institute was called why Darwin
matters evolution and the case against
intelligent design he's also the author
of science friction where the known
meets the unknown about how the
mind works and how thinking goes wrong
his book the science of good and evil
why people cheat gossip share cars and
follow the Golden Rule is on the
evolutionary origins of morality and how
to be good without religious faith he
also wrote the borderlands of science
about the fuzzy land between science and
pseudoscience and denying history on
Holocaust denial and other forms of
pseudo history his book how we believe
presents presents his theory on the
origins of religion and why people
believe in God and he's also the author
of why people believe weird things which
must do very well during presidential
election years dr. schirmer received a
PhD in the history of science from
Claremont Graduate School where he is
now an adjunct professor of economics in
his new book the mind of the market he
looks at evolution and economics how did
we make the leap from ancient
hunter-gatherers to modern consumers and
traders is the capitalist market place a
sort of Darwinian organism evolved
through natural selection as the fittest
way to satisfy our needs drawing on the
fields of neuro economics psychology
biology and other sciences he looks at
the economic roots the evolutionary
roots of modern economics please welcome
the author of the mind of the market
compassionate Apes competitive humans
and other tales from evolutionary
economics dr. Michael Shermer
well thank you David thanks for having
me it's good to be back in friendly
waters here amongst my fellow
libertarians and I'm on a book tour so
this is my first week of three weeks of
book touring and already it's rough you
know how it is when you're sleeping in a
different hotel every night you wake up
with the aches and pains and you get
that like kink in your neck and you have
to sort of you know like take it out
yourself like I'll show you show you
examples hang on for a second here oh
okay much better that's much better I
think we can continue now I'll show you
how to do that later in the Q&A my
headaches gone so I am the publisher of
skeptic magazine as the quarterly
publication of the society looks like
this we investigate claims of the
paranormal pseudoscience fringe groups
and cults and claims of all kinds
between science non-science voodoo
science junk science bad science
pathological science non-science and
plain old nonsense and unless you've
been on ducted by aliens have been on
Mars the last couple of decades you know
there's a lot of it out there nonsense
that is and it's our job to sort of
engage those people in claims to see if
they have any substance to them one of
our recent issues for example is on 911
conspiracy theories that is was there a
conspiracy at 911 conspiracy of course
there was al-qaeda is a conspiracy by
definition but that so called 911
truthers don't accept that explanation
they have their own conspiracy theory
that it was the Bush administration that
orchestrated 911 with hundreds or
thousands of operatives out there
planting bombs inside the World Trade
Center buildings operating the planes
with remote controls from local
buildings and and so on and so forth and
these are the same people by the way who
believe that Bush is the worst president
in the dumbest president we've ever had
in the history of civilization and yet
somehow he managed to pull off the most
elaborate intelligent conspiracy in the
history of civilization and that's
something of the dilemma they have
they're not one of these bomb planters
or conspirators has wanted to go on
Larry King to tell about what they did
and what they knew you know I mean this
is this alone tells us that it wasn't an
inside job but that's the kind of claim
that we try to sink our teeth into our
next issue is on global warming and so I
got a I got a global warming skeptic and
a global warming believer or whatever
the opposite of a skeptic would be I
guess sort of a left-wing scientist and
a right-wing scientist than the
scientists with no wings at all and and
try to have a balance there so the mind
of the market is a sort of an
extrapolation of what I've already been
doing we study human irrationality in
various aspects of life so if you stop
and think about it for just a moment you
realize there's no reason why
people would be irrational and in all
other aspects of life and then suddenly
when they walk into a supermarket or
they make an investment in the stock
market they become rational calculators
who don't make emotional investments or
something like that obviously that's not
true and so my book is the first to
integrate three new Sciences behavioral
economics neuro economics and
evolutionary economics on two levels one
is a descriptive level in which I'm
describing how people actually do behave
in the marketplace one of the
revolutionary transitions than in the
field of economics in the last 20 years
is that it's not being done by
economists anymore but by experimental
psychologists that is the two leaders in
this new field Amos Tversky and Daniel
Kahneman Kahneman who won the Nobel
Prize in Economics Tversky would have
but he died early they they never had a
single class in economics they were just
professional scientists know that know
how to run experiments and so instead of
mathematically predicting how people
should behave you actually put people in
real circumstances and you watch what
they actually do and these being real
people in the real world not just white
rats and labs and and an intro 18 year
old psych students and so the field has
gone far beyond what economics has
traditionally been so that's what kind
of makes it exciting I think and since
this is a reading of sorts i thought i
should do a little bit of reading and so
i'll read a few passages and then talk a
little bit more and and they will do
some Q&A so the second on the second
level so the part is descriptive and the
other part is prescriptive that is given
what we know about human nature about
our evolutionary past our behavioral
quirkiness and irrationality how should
we structure society to best enable the
spread of peace prosperity and freedom
and so forth and liberty what are what
are the right circumstances that we
should try to enable and so to that
extent I begin with the mind of the
market as a double entendre that is I
think the market has a mind of its own
that's one way to use it it's a
bottom-up self-organized system that
operates without
top down intelligent design if you will
and but also how the mind itself
operates in markets so i'm using the
mind of the market in a double way there
so in the first way that the market has
a mind of its own i start with chapter
one called the Great Leap Forward
somewhat with tongue and cheek to mister
maou with the problem that I'm trying to
solve in the book living along the
Orinoco River that borders Brazil and
Venezuela are the Yanomamo people
hunter-gatherers whose average annual
income has been estimated at the
equivalent of about a hundred dollars
per person per year if you walked into a
yanomami village and counted up the
stone tools and baskets arrow points and
arrow shafts bows cotton yarn carton and
vine hammocks clay pots assorted other
tools various medicinal remedies pets
food products articles of clothing and
the like you would end up with a figure
of around 300 before 10,000 years ago
this was the approximate material wealth
of every village on the planet if our if
our species is about a hundred thousand
years old the ninety percent of our
history has been spent in the state of
relative economic simplicity I'm taking
a hundred thousand years as the lower
limit of the estimate of the last
bottleneck migration out of Africa
somewhere between 160 thousand years ago
from which we all come today living
along the Hudson River that borders new
york and new jersey are the manhattan
people consumer traders whose average
annual income has been estimated at
forty thousand dollars per person per
year if you walked into the Yanomamo
village i'm inside of the manhattan
village and counted up all the different
products available at retail stores and
restaurants factory outlets and super
stores you'd end up with a figure of
around 10 billion as estimated by
stock-keeping units sk use that retail
measure by the bar codes which is now
exceeded 10 billion and they've just
added some more bars to make it a
hundred billion and then ultimately
they'll be a trillion so this difference
of 400 times an income and 33 million
times and product products
beggars description if ever there was a
great leap forward this was it
comparable to the evolution of
bipedalism the big brain and
consciousness equivalent to the
invention of fire the printing press and
the internet and on par with the
Agricultural Revolution the Industrial
Revolution and the digital revolution
and this great leap forward did not
happen gradually it's been estimated
that the hundred dollars per person per
year didn't rise to 150 per person per
year until 1000 BC about the time of the
end of the Bronze Age and the the time
of King David it did not exceed 200
dollars per person per year until after
1750 and the onset in the industrial
revolution in other words it took 97
thousand years to go from 100 to 150
bucks a person a year then another
twenty seven hundred fifty years to get
to two hundred dollars per person per
year and finally 250 years to ascend to
today's level of sixty six hundred
dollars per person per year for the
entire planet and as we just saw an
order of magnitude more for the
wealthiest people in the richest nations
so if we compress that hundred thousand
year period into just one year then the
last 250 year period of relative
prosperity would represent less than one
day out of the year or if we condense
the hundred millennium into a 24-hour
day our epoch of industrial production
and market economies accounts for a mere
three point six minutes in other words
the age in which we live and take for
granted is normal and the way things
I've always been in fact constitutes a
mere one quarter of one percent of human
history the question is how in the world
did this ever happen that's a weird
thing to have happen how can that happen
so that's the answer I'm trying to
provide in the book that's the coming
the problem I'm trying to solve I began
with complexity theory that is the
market and economies are self-organized
emergent properties that come out of
simpler systems without any top-down
design we already have much familiarity
with complex systems life itself appears
to have originated wherever in the
prebiotic soup and the surface of the
ocean the deep part of the ocean perhaps
even in in rocks but with just putting
energy into the system chemicals begin
to form more complex bonds and chains
they begin to formulate into crude cells
with cell cellular walls and so on
complex life itself cells themselves for
example the cells that were made out of
eukaryotic cells which contain little
organelles that you might remember from
high school biology that have all these
peculiar names but if you take one like
mitochondria and and remember that
mitochondrial DNA is how we trace our
genetic lineage through our mother's
line why would mitochondria have DNA our
cells already have DNA and their nucleus
lynn margulis is answer to this question
which i think is correct is that our
modern complex cells are composed of
these a conglomeration of these simpler
prokaryotic cells that themselves have
DNA in them so sometime between four
billion and three and a half billion
years ago these simpler cells began to
coalesce into larger complex cells
that's a form of self-organized emergent
property without any top-down design
just put energy into the system it
naturally happens a multicellular life
the immune system consciousness is
probably best explained as a
self-organized emergent property of a
hundred billion neurons firing in
patterns emerges out of this what we're
doing now whatever it is we're doing
thinking talking we're aware I'm aware
that you're aware i know that you know
that i know that in all that that good
theory of mind stuff that that has no
reductionistic explanation at the moment
and probably never will that is you have
to take it from the bottom up and build
not from the top down language is a
self-organized emergent complex system
nobody designed English 500 years ago to
sound like it does now or where I'm from
in Southern California where they use
the word like every three words you
couldn't design that and the legal
system the law system is a
self-organized emergent property and the
economy is what I'm trying to do is say
that the notion of free market economics
is one we're already familiar with if we
can hook it to things we already know
about so I'm trying to convince my
conservative friends that evolution
which they tend to be skeptical of is
just like that market economy stuff you
already understand and like and accept
and to my liberal friends who completely
accept evolution you know that free
market economy stuff you're skeptical of
look it's just like the evolution stuff
you fully accept and you know the
parallels are not perfect but they're
close enough and in fact in the mind of
the market i have a whole chapter on
darwin and adam smith these are the two
most famous metaphors in all of Western
culture the invisible hand and natural
selection and they are just metaphors
that can be misleading a natural
selection nobody is selecting anything
it's just whether organisms survive long
enough for their genes to make it into
the next generation however they might
do that whatever fittest means and so
polar bears which are the subject of
much angst over global warming and so on
they're not evolving to become marine
mammals or something they're not
becoming anything other than they might
become extinct they're just well adapted
to do exactly what they do so there's
nobody out there in the design space
future of life selecting organisms to
drive toward a certain direction
inevitably though because our minds are
design evolved the the way they are we
just tend to think of it that way and
and the same thing with the invisible
hand there's no hand directing down even
though the metaphor makes us think of
that and because of our vast experience
with design things r us designing them
we tend to think that complex objects
must be designed from the top down by an
intelligent being in fact what Smith met
was simply that as you already know
since you're familiar with this subject
that just people running around trying
to make a living just like organisms
running around trying to make a living
and all of us is trying to get our genes
in the next generation emerges out of
that this complexity without any need
for a top-down design now of course the
knowledge is not perfect markets have to
be situated in something some kind of
political system a country a nation of
some kind with laws and whatnot so it's
not completely designed 'less like life
but nevertheless
the the analogy is close enough so I
think one of the reasons I have a
chapter called folk economics in the
mind of the market which I address this
problem why don't people accept free
market economics and the answer is for
the same reason a lot of people have a
hard time with evolution our brains are
not well equipped to understand
intuitively these kinds of complex
long-term systems that change over time
we evolved in what Richard Dawkins calls
a middle world or what I likely prefer
for literate of purposes middle land
that is in the Paleolithic environment
and the plains of Africa where we
evolved the objects where of a middling
size sort of between ants and mountain
ranges and that's what our brains are
used to looking at and intuitively
comfortable with just sort of middling
sized objects running around in a
middling speed that you can see and and
we only live a few a few years to a few
decades so our concept of time is
relatively short between now which is
about three seconds long now up to a few
decades long that's it so the idea of
thousands of years of global climate
change is counterintuitive what do you
mean global warming it was cold the
other day and that's a typical response
you get simply because anecdotally were
used to thinking anecdotally what single
data points instead of long-term trends
are what we noticed the most and that's
because that's how our brains were
designed in this middle land and in this
middle land of our Paleolithic
environment in which we evolved in these
small groups of a couple dozen to a
couple hundred people there were no
market capital forces there was no
accumulation of wealth there was no
disparity between rich and poor these
are largely egalitarian communities so
the idea that there can be an invisible
hand or could be market forces there can
be a division of labor and all the stuff
that Smith writes about in the wealth of
nations none of that existed in our 99
percent of our history so there's
nothing in our brains that help us
immediately intuitively deeply grasp
that it requires effort on the part of
teachers to teach evolution because it
doesn't come naturally and an economist
to teach how this this works otherwise
people will naturally
rejected and so that goes a long way to
explaining i think that the resentment
of wealth that a lot of people have that
mistrust of corporations and and ceos a
minor that editorial cartoon in the new
yorker of the two characters in the
cocktail party in the one says to the
other one i hated bill gates before it
was so fashionable and you know it's
it's it's funny because we a lot of
people think like that but why should
they think like that and one reason i
think is because not only that that
intuitive a second reason would be that
most people equate evolution and
free-market economics with a with sort
of a view of human nature thats that
were a cutthroat selfish greedy and an
Tennyson's memorable fit phrase
describing nature red in tooth and claw
herbert spencer's description of
evolution as survival of the fittest
unfortunately those guys Huxley Spencer
they won that early battle shortly after
Darwin published the Origin of Species
it was a great debate about whether
natural selection just selected against
and was weeding out destroying you know
killing extinction and so on whether
that was the major thing or whether
natural selection was a creative force
creating designing and so on well it's
obviously it's both but Huxley and
Spencer sort of won that battle over
people like Peter Kropotkin who wrote a
book called mutual aid which he said
well no wait most of the organisms I see
in his native Russia were social animals
who are pretty pro-social and
cooperative or else they wouldn't have
been able to survive so now this maybe
there's an interesting sort of side
thing on how science is done and it
could it could be that because Kropotkin
was in a different political environment
than say the much more competitive and
capitalistic england maybe the view of
nature as competitive and greedy versus
cooperative and pro-social is in part
influenced by the culture in which
you're doing your science but
nevertheless i think we can still get at
the real answer and the real answer is
that of course most social animals are
most of the time pro-social and so on
and that if if we equated
evolution just as a cutthroat thing I
can see why people are uncomfortable
with it you'll often hear especially
right-wing political commentators who
are of say a Christian bent who think
evolution is somehow a threat to their
religion it isn't but why would they
think that and the main reason they
think that is because it means if
evolution is true we're not moral we're
just selfish and greedy and we're
animals will be doing it like they do on
the discovery channel is somebody wrote
in a song and this explains a Columbine
for example seriously one of the
explanations for the shooting at
Columbine was because we're teaching
evolution to our kids right well this is
a misunderstanding of evolution and so
I'll transition them to economics by
noting that Jeffrey's killings favorite
book mr. Enron Jeffrey's killings
favorite book at the harvard business
school when he was a student there was
Richard Dawkins The Selfish Gene which
he said you see this is evolution
cutthroat competitive greed is good
Gordon Gekko that's capitalism well if
that was capitalism capitalism would
have imploded centuries ago it can't
operate that way the reason it can
operate that way is because it's not in
our nature as a social species before
Adam Smith was a famous for the wealth
of nations he was a professor moral
philosophy in his first book was a
Theory of Moral Sentiments in which he
stated right there and got right this is
before Darwin and so he didn't have the
mechanism but that we are in fact deeply
intuitively innately empathetic and
sympathetic to our fellow social group
members and that a market system and a
civil society could not operate if it
were not that case he said we literally
put ourselves in somebody else's shoes
and feel their pain or feel their
pleasure and this is what we now today
call a theory of mind I know that you
know that I know that you know and we're
back to that again and so there has to
be something like that in order for it
to work so other things I'm trying to do
in the mind of the market is say look
it's not free market economics has been
hooked to the wrong theory of evolution
and it isn't like that at all so I have
a chapter contrasting and Ron with
Google and and sort of teasing those
apartments showing how
really is an anomaly it has to be an
anomaly if most corporations were run
like that the system wouldn't work most
corporations are more like Google which
stands out a little bit because it's
it's famous and they give away free food
to all their employees and they do all
these cool things not everybody does
that but the principle of don't be evil
is is I think really embraced by most
businessmen it's just that that doesn't
make the news okay now the question is
why should why should that be and here's
here's an additional problem to solve
from an evolutionary perspective why
should I be cooperative nice honest fair
and just in my dealing with other people
well kin selection theory says I will do
that to those who I'm related to because
they're my kin and therefore I am
passing my genes along in the next
generation by helping somebody who's
related to me genetically okay no
problem Robert rivers and others figured
this out mathematically with social
species especially in the 1970s and
Wilson began to try to apply this in in
his in the late 70s in his book
sociobiology but that was disputed by
Steve gold and Dick Lewington at Harbor
and this became a big culture wars
battle that in the long run wilson won
ed ed came out on top on that debate
simply because the data supported him
but the theory mutated from sociobiology
to evolutionary psychology so it's an
odd thing really that Darwin started
this whole thing off in the descent of
man and and the expression of the
emotions of man and then it just lied
dormant until the 1990s it really was
until just ten years ago that it became
okay to study used evolutionary models
to study human behavior and so
evolutionary economics is really sort of
the latest version of that but what
about strangers well people that I know
pretty well that are not related to me
or that I have a lot of interaction with
that that's explainable by something
called reciprocal altruism I'll scratch
your back if you'll scratch mine but
that only works if I can have experience
with you to know that you're trustworthy
and that you will reciprocate in the
long run the next step beyond that in
that
expanding circle of sentiments is hot
what about strangers and other groups
people that are not related to us and
that we don't even know we have no
experience with the complete strangers
the normal natural thing to do if you're
a hunter-gatherer when you run into
somebody from another tribe is turn and
run or kill him and that's typically
what happens unless something else
happens and that's something else is
reciprocity a kind of exchange we would
say trade in the modern world but any
kind of opportunity you have to interact
with somebody in a positive fashion in
which I give you something you give me
something we have some kind of operative
exchange that's a mechanism for breaking
down the natural tribal barriers that we
evolved and to knock back though
xenophobic tendencies where we naturally
fear strangers we know this from a
series of research in and behavioral
economics and neuro economics and I'll
go through some of those now so here's a
thought experiment for you imagine
you're walking along a railroad line and
there's a there's a split in the track
and you're standing there next to the
switch the train is due to go down the
right track here and here it comes you
look back it's hurting down the track
and it's going to go down the right
track here where there's five workers
that it will run over and kill on the
left track however is just one worker
and if you throw the switch the train
will go to the left and kill the one
worker and save the five should you
throw the switch kill one to save five
so most people who take this little
experiment you can do this at the mark
Hauser's webpage at Harvard you can take
the test yourself see how you do not
exactly a right answer but anyway most
people say yeah of course I throw the
switch okay second scenario you're
there's a railroad track and you're on a
bridge over the track and standing next
to you is a large hefty band and the
train is hurtling down there's five
workers right there on the track and you
have the opportunity to throw the big
guy off the bridge he lands on the track
smack goes the Train he's killed but the
train stops the five workers are saved
would you shove the guy off the bridge
you got to just actually just give him a
hip check or boom you got to physically
throw him off would you do it most
almost everybody says no they would not
do it with a visceral sense that this
would sit this would really be wrong
why it's the same moral calculation kill
one to save five why are they different
the reason is that switches and people
are categorically different and
evolution explains why evolution
designed us to value humans over
nonhumans can over non-kin friends over
strangers in group members versus
out-group members and direct action over
indirect action because those
differences impacted survival and
reproduction these intuitively felt
differences in moral intuitions reflect
a rational calculation conducted over
the evolutionary eons what may seem like
irrational behavior today may actually
be have been rational deep in our
Paleolithic past so when I what I build
on there from my previous book the
science of good and evil is that moral
emotions evolved as a proxy for
something else so emotions themselves
have a purpose the emotions take up
brain power brains are expensive to run
they must be there for a reason what do
emotions do you know if we think of the
human body as a as a homeostatic system
which is almost always out of balance on
some level emotions are pushing us
they're motivators to do something to
correct the imbalance so the motion of
hunger for example drives the organism
to seek calories to balance the
imbalance of not enough calories right
so hunger is an emotion that drives
behavior that's simple we get that
slightly more complex but still in that
realm is say sexual attraction or
attractiveness to somebody else and and
we now have a pretty good handle on on
what it is that other people find that
people find attractive and other people
women find attractive in men men that
are broad shoulder with a sort of
pyramid shape too narrow or waist
symmetrical faces clear complexions
these are proxies for something for
genetic health and men finding women
attractive miss the hourglass shape the
again symmetrical faces clear complexion
and especially a point six seven waist
to hip ratio point six seven waist hip
ratio now nobody walks into a bar and
says
that is a point 69 close enough for me
doing the calculation of attractiveness
pretty symmetrical face we put a mirror
up there and soon you don't have to do
that calculation because evolutions
already done the calculating for us
these are proxies for genetic health the
emotions simply tell us just like I'm
hungry wow I have a good feeling about
this person I will walk over there it's
a motivation to bit to bathe to change
behavior obviously driven to get your
genes into the next generation right and
so if we just keep moving up from that
model to higher let's say higher moral
principles why not shove somebody off
that well because a direct physical
visceral contact with somebody else
touches on those deep emotional parts of
our brain the amygdala for example and a
cause those to light up and and tell us
that would be wrong whereas a switch is
much more viscerally removed from sort
of that ancestral environment and and we
know this from lots of experiments and
getting back to that business of
description as well as prescriptive
aspects of the mind of the market in
another one of these not thought
experiments an actual behavior you can
do there's a game called the ultimatum
game that behavioral economists like to
employ in which let's say here's a
couple of a young men here let's say you
guys are too starving students at my
university and you come in to my lab to
participate in my experiment I have a
hundred bucks I give you a hundred bucks
now you have an option to make an offer
to him not an option you have to make
him an offer of a split of the hundred
dollars if he expected accepts your
offer you both get to keep the money if
he rejects your offer I'm taking the
money back and neither of you gets any
money at all now what should he offer
him as a split now according to Homo
economicus that is humans are rational
calculators free to choose and selfish
maximizers or utility maximizers he
should offer him let's say a 9010 split
he gets
ten bucks I'm keeping 90 and and he
should accept it because he's a poor
starving student he just walked in the
lab with no money and he can turn around
right now walk out with 10 bucks they
almost always reject that offer so an
economist would say this guy is willing
to pay ten dollars to me to punish this
bastard for making an unfair offer they
use language like that why why not take
the 10 but it's not fair damn it what do
you mean is not fair who says it's not
fair there's no law about the ultimatum
game what you must offer it's an
intuitive deep sense that something is
wrong here it's not fair and that sense
appears to cross almost all cultures
this is now been this research has now
been done in cultures non-western
cultures around the world in even and
hunter-gatherer communities they don't
use cash so you have to you have to use
other proxies for what we would call
money Franz Duval has even found similar
results in primates chimpanzees which
have decent sized brains capuchin
monkeys which don't they have tiny
little brains chimps are directly
related to us maybe split off six
million years ago and capuchin monkeys
maybe 15 million years ago so the task
is this you've got a two chimps in two
cages here and separated by a barrier
but they can see each other and they
have two ropes they have to pull this
platform up from down below if one of
them poles the other one doesn't the
platform tips and on the platform is a
bucket of well that they don't like
money but they like fruit nice fresh cut
fruit on a little bowl of ice very
delicious right so if they both pull it
up the platform comes up the bucket
comes into one of the cages only and
this is going to be an iterated game
where they do it over and over and you
know they haven't eaten since yesterday
so they're motivated that Hungary motion
kicks in and the question is what will
this one chimp or capuchin monkey do
will he share or not when they share
it's iterated over and over and a good
time as head bay all and they're well
fed when he doesn't share the other guy
refuses to participate they get upset
they throw things it's it's really quite
an amusing set of experiments because
although it's a bit of
anthropomorphizing but clearly they're
upset they have no language to say
was unfair you bastard but they do have
a sense obviously on some deep level
that there there was an injustice done
it was wrong to do that and and so why
should that be and I'm arguing we
haven't evolved deep evolve sense of
right and wrong and that includes a
sense of fairness about exchange now
when we're talking about modern
economies we think of money and market
exchanges and things like that but let's
broaden the idea to an economy is any
social environment in which there's
kinds of exchanges turns out for example
that when chimpanzees are grooming one
another yes there's health benefits
right they pick off the tix and so on
and there's even sort of a soothing
social bonding thing where you get a
little spike in oxytocin and and being
touched feels good and there's a
relaxation and so on but there's a third
level in which grooming actually sets up
a social relationship and a type of
reciprocity when chimp a groom's chimp
be when Jimmy gets in a fight with chimp
see chip a is more likely to help them
so it's a form of political alliance
this kind of exchange in in this market
economy of social chips a form of
political alliance to form some
alliances with maybe the alpha male
who's a little bit nasty but the two of
us are better than one that kind of
thing so that's a form of exchange and
that appears to be so the point of the
primate research is to say this isn't
unique to us that there's an
evolutionary past that goes back at
least 15 million years just there's
hundreds of these experiments that I
summarized in the mind of the market but
but just one more that you can change
train these capuchin monkeys to exchange
pebbles for a fruit so the pebbles
become a form of money and you train
them and you see what their preferences
are you train them to say like apple
slices cost two stones and a banana
slice costs three pebblez or whatever
and and and then you start you start a
little exchanging when they get hungry
they give you some money and you give
them the fruit right so you figure out
what their preferences are what they
like more they're willing to pay more
for and so on and then in the second
condition you simply double the price of
one of the fruits to see what happens
with the supply and demand curve and
that's apply and demand curve
beautifully matches human
supply and demand preferences and values
exactly as you would predict
mathematically from the amount of the
product that's available and the price
that it costs so the deeper evolutionary
reasons for why we respond in supply and
demand situations like that at least
goes back 15 million years so that would
be yet another indication that this is
how we operate so and then finally
looking at sort of the neuro economics
of this two sets of research one is on
neuro economics we actually scan the
brains of subjects who are doing these
games the ultimatum game prisoner's
dilemma type games and you see which
areas of the brain are lighting up turns
out that dopamine rich areas in the
brain a light up the most when subjects
are cooperating when they're getting a
lot of money in a positive exchange
going on there a dopamine is the drug
that's the reward drug it's it's
associated with addictive behaviors of
all kinds gambling and alcohol and
especially drugs but it's also
associated with sex and and seeing sexy
pictures and things like that these
dopamine centers light up it's a
cooperation in exchange games between
total strangers in the lab generates
these brain centers to light up to cause
reward pathways to be reinforced in a
second set of experiments done by my
friend and colleague at Claremont
Graduate University Paul's Zach Paul is
the well he's the oxytocin man it says
so right on his license plate you know
this is California right so we have to
signal to everybody what we are well
it's really not we guys got is a guy
thing anyway that's caused by
testosterone most likely but that's a
different subject and and so what Paul
is done is run these experiments the
ultimatum game the prisoner's dilemma
there's an iterated ultimatum game where
you guys go back and forth and you keep
swapping money for say ten rounds to see
how much cooperation goes on and he
draws their blood literally I mean
you're in a lab and you really got to
pay the subjects a lot to get this
because it's an uncomfortable thing but
they draw their blood he measures
oxytocin levels which go up dramatically
when the subjects are cooperating and
goes down dramatically when they're not
this has to be done very quickly the
half-life of oxytocin is only a few
minutes oxytocin remember is the bonding
attachment a hormone that nursing
mothers have with their infants but it
turns out it's it goes up with couples
in love it goes up with anybody that's
that's a handshake touching one another
Paul actually had subjects get massaged
by a professional massage therapist and
they were much more cooperative made
more generous donations you would
imagine the ethics committees reading
these you're going to bring in a massage
therapist okay and then finally to test
the cause the causal vector which way is
the arrow going is oxytocin the cause of
the effect of cooperative trade and the
answer is it's it's if you take a nose
spray and you give subjects a shot of
oxytocin through a nose spray goes right
through the blood-brain barrier quickly
they are much more cooperative much more
generous so this oxytocin appears to be
a generator a social glue as that calls
it for holding society together so we've
gone now from and I'll wrap it up here
with reading one final passage here with
going back to our Yanomamo example with
something that I call a Basquiat sprint
that is where goods do not cross
frontiers armies will Basquiat sprint
cipal not only helps us understand how
hunter-gatherers made the transition to
consumer traders it also illuminates one
of the primary causes of conflict and
its corollary elucidates one of the
principal steps toward conflict
resolution if bastia its principle holds
that were goods do not cross frontiers
armies will then his corollary dictates
that where goods do not cross front do
cross frontiers armies will not this is
a principle not a law since there are
exceptions historically and today trade
will not prevent war but it attenuates
its likelihood thinking in terms of
probabilities instead of absolutes trade
between groups increases the probability
that peaceful and stable relations will
continue and decreases the probability
that instabilities and conflicts will
erupt so let's return to the Yanomamo
people and how they evolved into
Manhattan consumer traders
when missionaries first began working
with the Yanomamo they discovered that
if they provided the native peoples with
tools for the procurement and production
of food and other resources the amount
of Yanomamo inter village fighting was
greatly reduced the great Yanomamo
ethnographer Napoleon Chagnon originally
gave the Yanomamo their fierce people
moniker his monogram was Jana model but
fierce people he discovered that the
Yanomami are sophisticated traders as
well as ferocious warriors because trade
creates political alliances following
the political dictum the enemy of my
enemy is my friend Yanomamo inter
village trade and reciprocal food
exchanges serve as a powerful social
glue in the creation of political
alliances village a cannot go to village
B and announced that they're worried
about being conquered by the more
powerful village C says that would
reveal their own weakness instead
village a forms an alliance with village
be through trade and reciprocal feasting
and as a result they not only gain
military protection but also encourage
inner village peace as a byproduct of
this politically motivated economic
exchange even though each yanomami band
could produce all the sk use it needs
for survival they often set up a
division of labor and a system of trade
the unintended consequence is an
increase in both wealth and products the
animal trade not because their na altura
certa sont capitalists but because they
want to form political alliances and as
chagnon rights without these frequent
contacts with neighbors alliances would
be much slower in formation and would be
even more unstable once formed a
prerequisite to stable alliances
repetitive visiting and feasting and the
trading mechanism serves to bring about
these visits in other words where
Yanomamo where goods across llamo
frontiers are yanomami armies do not
cross frontiers and that's I think a
principle we can extrapolate out and the
reason for it is this deep evolutionary
sense of somehow breaking down these
natural tribal xenophobic barriers we
have and what I would say the Google
fication and Starbucks ification and
open trade between countries is
absolutely the best and only way
to at its deepest level get past those
natural xenophobic barriers thank you
all right before we break for lunch and
book signing will take questions there
will be microphones brought to you
please wait for the microphone and
please have a question where are the
microphones there they are Michael you
want to call on oh sure uh let's see how
well can start off down here I guess you
want to bring the mic down here what is
your opinion of the NAFTA and CAFTA
arrangements well I mean I don't follow
those things that closely but any kind
of arrangements in which we can have
greater free trade between peoples is a
good thing I'm from California so one
solution to the immigration problem and
I'm amazed that this has become a
political issue we've had Mexicans
pouring into california since i was born
in the 50's i don't know why this became
suddenly became a thing has always been
there and in simply market forces have
always dealt with it so i would say open
the borders and open trade in this sense
for example when I need to I have a big
hill side it has to be clear because i
live in fire country so the fire
department requires us to clear it every
year and I would do it anyway because
that's what causes your house houses to
burn down right so I just go down to
local home depot and they're just out
there waiting but there's this kind of a
sense like I'm doing something wrong or
whatever but they want to do it I want
to pay them I don't care whether if they
send the money back what do I care I
mean I got the I got the job done and so
on if there were too many of them and
usually there are the market was simply
send a lot of them back because they
can't find work if there's too many
already weed-whacking or whatever it is
they're doing in in California there so
i would say that is a model for
expanding in principle opening up those
trades the market would determine how
many immigrants are coming in well
you're standing there might look at this
one they would go up there or you want
to do it up there ok go just go
start here and there nothing to Mike
from there yep rule do unto others as
you haven't do unto you could this be a
bottom-up evolutionary survival morality
yes the golden rule is reciprocal
altruism I mean it is a form of
reciprocity that is practiced by all
social animals so it's the first
principle well that's what the great
rabbi Hillel said when asked about you
know interpreting the Bible and all the
400 laws and all that he said basically
do unto others and all the rest is
commentary and that's right and that
really begins at just basic primate
social behavior and and that's what we
are so that's why I claim that we are
innately moral to theists who say you
can't be good without god I say well
thank thanks for the warning in case you
don't stop believing but but that in
fact now of course we all are moral and
and that the morality evolved first see
what happened was about five to seven
thousand years ago all those informal
means of behavior control like
reciprocity reciprocal altruism and all
that only works in small groups once
populations are in the tens and hundreds
of thousands do you need some sort of
codified set of rules so we had two
institutions evolved government religion
um Bert Ely from here in the Washington
area on page 20 in the introduction you
talk about you now disagree with ran
death except self-interest and wonder if
you could expand upon that a little bit
and going a little bit to what extent
you're trying to have any influence on
the R & ian's in terms of trying to help
them move past where r and was more in
line with what your own thinking is well
I'm not trying to move anybody anywhere
i'm just a scientist to saying this is
the way it is and we can adjust our
political preferences and commitments
based on that I mean I most of Rands
philosophy i think is correct terrific
you know objectivism and so on but but
the idea that
we're just just selfish beans i think
mrs. the better half i'm not sure what
you would say about that ad hudgens here
can collect clarify i'm sure and in the
social hour afterwards but but that I
think again goes I think one of the
objections people have do objectivism is
that oh it's that selfish greedy
philosophy and I kind of don't feel good
about that and so there's another way to
say no but actually capitalism is
incredibly moral markets have to be
moral if they weren't moral it would
never work so it this this is an
exercise and consciousness-raising I'm
trying to raise everybody's
consciousness to say this is the most
moral system ever developed so instead
of saying it's the opposite let's just
keep saying it and eventually we'll get
it here David David Bernstein George
Mason University Law School I'm a
subscriber to skeptic and a big fan I
recommend it to I think it only audience
I've also read a couple of your books
have one thing I got out of that as well
other things I've read is that people
have all sorts of reasons for believing
what they believe about the world the
reason is often reason logic etc is
often not one of them symbols and
emotion all that so for those of us who
deal in ideas that would include
yourself David running a think tank and
myself being a law professor how much or
how much a factor just rational argument
have what percentage of people are
actually ultimately susceptible to
reason why there's some differences why
are some people skeptics here some
people are the opposite and is that a
function actually of our who we were
born from and what genes we've inherited
or is it how we were educated if the
school system taught reason people will
be more reasonable well hopefully we
like to think education makes a
difference and by the way asked about
this skeptic magazine I passed around a
clipboard there if you want to put your
email address on there that's for the
electronic version of skeptic magazine
that goes out every week it's free
anyway so obviously I wouldn't be in
that business if I didn't think it
matters i mean we teach critical
thinking and reason and rationality and
and and fortunately our brains are very
pliable and incapable of learning so
yeah naturally we we hope that makes a
difference
unfortunately unfortunately I have job
security because we'll never solve the
problem because our brains are designed
by evolution to learn called Association
learning a is connected to B and
oftentimes a really is connected to be
in some causal way what we don't have is
a baloney detection module in our brain
to pick out those false positives where
a looks like it's connected to be but in
fact it's not which is why places like
Las Vegas are so successful and so we're
up against that and always will be
that's the the intuitive problem i said
with understanding things like long-term
global change or long-term climate or
like civilization changes or economic
changes that we just can't get our minds
around those so that that's a problem
and an economic level we're pretty
irrational as I mentioned those three
aspects of Homo economicus that we're
rational free and and Max selfishly
maximizing that those are all debunk
those are all bunk that myth has been
debunked and so things like the
ultimatum game is an example of that
that's an irrational thing or if I give
you an offer of a like a choice so you
walk into a store then there's the
widget you want to buy an ipod or
something that's a hundred bucks and I
tell you you look four blocks down the
street it's only 50 bucks would you
would you walk down and get it almost
everybody says well yeah sure I mean
four blocks fifty bucks it's half off
I'll do it second scenario you're in the
same store you're going to buy that
plasma TV it's a thousand bucks I say
hey you look four blocks away it's only
nine hundred and fifty dollars you're
going to go get it almost everybody says
toe fifty bucks I mean it's the same
fifty dollars but it's framed in a
different scenario so this is called the
framing effect there's about 20
different of these cognitive biases that
influence an emotional level what we
value financially and so that that makes
it anything but rational Michael I'd
like to ask follow-up to that I wonder
if you've read the book by bryan caplan
the myth of the rational voter and how
that affects how rational our people and
are they less rational when they vote
then when they operate their own lives
yeah I haven't read that book but I
think that's probably right i mean we're
social primate species so we very much
move in herds we like being in groups
it's important for us to be in groups
and we like our alpha male so i mean
thats all sort of fits the research i've
seen on this is once you make a
commitment to a position then the
confirmation bias kicks in and you
justify the reasons for your commitment
to that particular position and it's the
farther down the road you gar the harder
it is to change that because you've
accumulated a lot of evidence in favor
of the position you're at whether it's
real or not is there sort of irrelevant
I did like there's a book called the
political brain drew westen is a neuro
scientist at Emory and and so his
argument is that he's a Democrat he
liberal and he advises Democratic
candidacies and he says you guys
Democrats we we Democrats he says I've
made a big mistake thinking we can
reason and rationalize our way to the
voters brains he said forget the brains
go for the heart go for the forget the
prefrontal cortex go for the amygdala
you know fear the terrorists are coming
and you know that's the level that most
brains operate in up till now the
Democrats have been operating on reason
well this is what he thinks it's a good
points here we go this woman here
Deborah would Smith the president
accounts on competitiveness I loved your
talk it was fantastic thank you I have a
question you didn't talk at all about
the gender differences and if you look
at some of the great historical trading
nations from the Egyptians the Vikings
women had a very interesting prominent
role in society you can think of the
English how would you factor in this
openness this reciprocity and how
females have been treated and empowered
throughout history and how does that
have a genetic basis and what you're
talking about interesting question I
haven't given that that much thought in
some of these game theory models the
women tend to be more trusting initially
and they cooperate and give more
than men the idea is that testosterone
makes you a little more skeptical of
other people's trustworthiness until
it's proven in Zacks research he fact he
finds that about two to three percent of
his subjects respond not at all to
oxytocin I mean you could give him a
bucket full of it and he calls them the
bastards and and this happens to also be
the percentage of sociopaths in society
it's possible that there's just a
percentage of the poppy if you have a
law of large numbers you have enough
people you're going to get some outliers
that are six standard deviations out and
they just respond to nothing in the same
way that the rest of us do and but but
Paul adds an interesting twist on this
that I talk about in the book and that
we worked on a little bit that maybe the
bastards i call them zacks bastards
maybe they're the ones that keep us the
rest of us sort of finely tuned in our
moral calculations because they keep us
on our toes you can't be too trustworthy
so it requires more signals of trust so
more social institutions that enable
those trust signals to be sent so you
can tell the difference between the the
bastards and everybody else something
that probably be something like that
here we go Eric for turkey earth NPR
part of what you seem to be saying is
that seemingly irrational behaviors
often have evolutionary rationales
behind them and so I guess I'm wondering
where the line between descriptive and
prescriptive is that you mentioned it at
the beginning yes good question i don't
really have a line i think it's a fuzzy
boundary in which i don't fully accept
the whole you know you can't do a lot
from it is and and the the naturalistic
fallacy I don't fully accept that I
think in this age it's okay to at least
apply signs to the extent that you can
to try to resolve moral conflicts on two
levels one we have to apply science to
understand why people are moral but then
the next question is is what's the more
actual right moral decision to make and
you know philosophers have had and
theologians have had free rein on this
question for 4,000 years and Ed Wilson
said at the end of sociobiology it's
time to take
get away well you have to take it away
from them but scientists have something
to say about this and this is what my my
friend my literary agent John Brockman
calls the third culture and John has
kind of created this environment of
science books science books that are not
technical books they're not popular
books there what I call integrative
science books they're they're
integrating lots of new areas of science
in a new and creative way by
professional scientists jared diamond's
Guns Germs and Steel is the classic case
of this i think that's not the popular
version of jared's original research
it's the only version there is and and
to that extent I think it's okay for
scientists to jump in there and say I
think this is the right moral decision
based on this evidence and they may be
wrong but at least there's another voice
in the another voice in the conversation
thanks dad Hutchins atlas society by the
way the good news is a objectivism
doesn't contradict anything you said so
okay good anyway but my question
concerns your definition of being
rational and being a skeptic and being
moral you of course would say as a
skeptic that we should examine
rationally any kind of claims you know
about UFOs or whatever it happens to be
you also point out correctly that our
capacities have evolved for example our
capacity tastes for certain kind of
foods so therefore I have a taste for
sweet foods and fat and I could eat a
whole lot of them but as a
self-conscious person I also recognize
that if I give in to that particular
urge they're going to be adverse effects
therefore I constrain that evolutionary
capacity and the same thing for a whole
lot of other capacities would you say
that part of being a skeptic part of
being rational and part of being moral
is to pull back and exercise that thing
that is called self consciousness free
will whatever label you want to put on
it and to say how is this going to
maximize my enjoyment pleasure and i
would say higher you know happiness in
life is that part of what it is to be a
skeptic in what it is to be moral
absolutely as Katharine Hepburn said to
hunt free bogart and the African Queen
nature mr. Allen nuts is what we were
put on this earth to rise
both yep it's a great question we're
back here looks like maybe or here's one
we haven't heard from over here either
those two hi I've been Queen um you
mentioned that based on your
evolutionary theory of capitalism that
Enron's the exception rather than the
rule is it possible that a certain
proportion of corporations in the free
market will try to take advantage based
on evolutionarily stable strategies that
a certain most will go by the rule of
love but inevitably someone will come
along and try to take advantage of yes
of course absolutely and it's a good
point to make and and the same model
would apply to athletes who dope so I
just finished this big article cover
story for Scientific American that will
come out in the April issue in time for
opening day of baseball in which I
applied a game theory model to this it's
the same principle as it would be for
good for corporations or CEOs or anybody
else that is you have a game with the
set of rules and boundaries and the
rules have to be enforced if they're not
then once defection begins especially at
the top the closest competitors have to
also defect if the say in this case the
drugs make a difference and boy they
really do make a difference now back in
the 50s and 60s when athletes began
doping it was questionable about whether
those drugs actually made a performance
difference or not now they have it down
to a science and if they make like ten
to twenty percent difference you have to
do it and if the system itself doesn't
enforce the rules then then defection
will become the rule and that's what's
happened in sports that's what would
happen possibly if there weren't some
system in which a market operated some
kind of a sort of a liberal democracy
with the rule of law and and court
systems and a fair and free fair justice
system and and things like that that the
kinds of rules we put down I think say
may be environmentally we as a society
decide here's how much carbon we want to
allow into the environment every year
and then now it's up to you guys to free
trade you know carbon credits and so on
and let the market figure that out I
think that's a nice solution to that and
so something something along those lines
let's take two more questions there's a
couple
that there's a woman in the back there
and then a gentleman in the back oh if
somebody up front here crystal Chavez
from Los Angeles California thank you so
much for talking tonight today well
liberals ever learn or evolved to
embrace capitalism obviously at work and
they're not understanding the mechanisms
of it and still are hindering you know a
progress liberals ever learned well it
has stopped the question right there
that's too funny well sure I mean you
know their people and and like anybody
else you know they want peace prosperity
and freedom and so on so it's really
their back to our question about
education yes of course hopefully we can
basically raise everybody's
consciousness to realize that markets
are moral and that free markets are an
effective way at providing justice and
fairness to more people and more wealth
and more prosperity and so on and and
that's part of the reason I wrote the
mind of the market but other people are
doing this think tanks like Cato reason
and so on and it's really a culture war
in a sense and and raising consciousness
is what you do in a culture war by just
saying it enough and providing cogent
arguments in favor of it we had this
gentleman right here and then that'll be
our last one day we could talk
afterwards a at lunch too I'm glad you
mentioned culture since up to this point
there is no everyone talked about the
Western point of view not the Asian
point of view I'm from China originally
and I if I may say so Your your analysis
is coated with the so-called Alliance
but basically it is domination you're
not r you talk about sharing and you
evenly using a very simple example 1010
breaking a hundred-dollar bill into 1090
is not shared ring in a sense its
domination you know you try to dominate
people and I in the Chinese
interview what why don't you do simply
live and let live and let them decide on
for themselves without your intervention
and eventually domination well I guess I
wouldn't disagree with you is if we have
a free society with free markets that
people will decide for themselves and if
you don't want to participate in some
sort of economic exchange game well then
don't you don't have to nobody has to do
anything it's only when you start
intervening into the rules too much that
then then you end up with domination
things like the dominating attempts and
colonialism and things like that it's
that zero-sum model that most of the
Paleolithic environment actually is that
leads to things like mercantilism and
tribalism in the in the market forces it
once you take that out then you don't
really have to worry about things like
domination anyway thank you so much for
coming thank you David Thank You cato
institute and we invite everybody to
join us upstairs for lunch and michael
shermer is the founding publisher of
skeptic magazine and a columnist for
Scientific American magazine he's the
author of many books including why
people believe weird things and the
science of good and evil for more
information visit Michael Shermer com
his